the movie starts at a house party where
several people have gathered as they are
enjoying their time the power suddenly
goes out as a result the party hosts who
are also best friends Jonah Stevie and
Gus start looking for the source of the
problem after a bit of searching Stevie
finds out that the electricity bill has
not been paid in three months here we
get to know that the friends are living
in Jonah's house and they organize a
party every weekend so that they can
earn money desperate to keep the party
running Jonah heads to his cocky
neighbor Silvio and makes a deal with
him in exchange for electricity he then
quickly Sprints back to his friends
without telling them that he has
actually made a deal when Stevie and Gus
show their appreciation to Silvio for
helping them out the latter mentions
that he will need 500 and a bottle of
vodka first as promised by Jonah enraged
Gus confronts his Carefree friend and
mentions that they don't have the money
to pay Silvio however Jonah comes up
with a plan and announces to everyone
that they are short on money in no time
the partygoers start donating to the
cause and the electricity comes back
after this the party continues in full
swing with everyone going wild meanwhile
an intoxicated Jonah heads to his
bedroom with a girl named Becky and
starts kissing her during the ACT Becky
notices a weird lump in Jonah's genitals
and mentions it to him at first Jonah
ignores it but later when Becky starts
describing the lump he realizes that
something is wrong in the next scene
Jonah visits a doctor where he is put
through a series of tests later he
visits the same doctor in his office and
learns that he has testicular cancer
hearing this Jonah is shocked and is
left speechless however the doctor
consoles him by saying that testicular
cancer is the best cancer to get as its
treatment is very effective and cheap he
also mentions that the treatment is
risk-free but for it to be successful
they will have to remove one testicle
this further worries Jonah and he
immediately asks the doctor if he will
still be capable of doing romantic
activities the answer is yes but the
doctor reveals that he will become
infertile forever meaning he won't be
able to conceive any babies despite this
he can still reproduce in other ways
later Jonah collects his semen in a jar
hoping that he can use it after a few
years later he breaks the news to his
best friends and they are left stunned
by the Revelation nevertheless they
encourage him to be strong as the cancer
isn't too serious Gus and Stevie also
decide to cancel next week's house party
but Jonah refuses mentioning that it
will ruin their momentum the next day
Jonah gets a call from the hospital and
quickly departs there a nurse mentions
to him that despite his semen being
perfectly healthy it somehow couldn't
pass the freeze procedure making it
unsuitable for reproduction this
devastates Jonah and he asks the nurse
if there are other ways to have babies
after a bit of staring the nurse simply
replies by asking if he has a girlfriend
in the next scene Jonah heads to the
party and starts drinking excessively
while in a drunken State he starts
asking random girls if they would like
to reproduce with him but since they are
also drunk they ignore him the following
morning Stevie drives Jonah to his
sister Katie on reaching there a worried
Katie starts asking him several
questions but Jonah can't take his eyes
off of her children he feels that he
only has a few days to find a solution
or else he will never be able to become
a father determined to find a partner he
even contacts his ex-girlfriend Eva who
he hasn't spoken to in the last four
months the duo has an awkward
conversation and when Ava asks the
reason for their meet up Jonah suddenly
reveals that he wants to have babies
since Ava does not know about his
condition she becomes enraged and
belittles Jonah for being immature in
the evening a dejected Jonah visits his
doctor for a regular checkup the doctor
mentions that he can line up a surgery
appointment in three days but Jonah
mentions that it's too early when he
asks about the next appointment date the
doctor tells him that it's three weeks
away he also suggests that Jonah take
the nearest available slot as cancer
spreads fast however Jonah who is
adamant on having a baby confirms that
he wants to take the second appointment
as it will give him 21 days to find a
partner in the next scene Jonah decides
to approach Becky who is notorious for
sleeping with many men his friends try
their best to stop him but Jonah does
not listen later he arrives at Becky's
Place who is equally excited to meet him
Jonah then reveals the entire situation
to Becky and says that he wants a
partner to have babies with this shocks
Becky and she mentions that despite
Jonah being a wonderful person she
doesn't love him enough to have a child
with him once again Jonah returns home
dejected now with time running out he
starts talking to random people from the
internet and even meets some of them
physically however each of his attempts
go in vain as all the girls back out
when they find that he wants to have
babies with them one morning Stevie is
at a restaurant with her boyfriend when
she suddenly notices Jonas sitting alone
in a corner a while later he comes over
to Stevie and in front of her boyfriend
mentions that he cannot adopt children
because of a strange law that prohibits
cancer patients from adopting after
saying this much he heads outside and
sits alone on the footpath Stevie tries
to ignore it but her boyfriend suggests
she go out and talk to her friend later
Jonah and Stevie have some beers and
discuss the matter at hand Stevie
suggests Jonah go after single older
women or even lesbians if he really
wants to have babies she also mentions
that the whole process will just be an
arrangement and there will be no
intimacy involved in it Jonah is
skeptical about the idea but when he
realizes that he has no other options he
agrees with this Stevie sets up a
meeting with one of her colleagues
Allison who is a lesbian the following
day Stevie and Jonah meet Allison who is
her girlfriend soon the two women start
bombarding Jonah with questions they ask
him what he will do after becoming a
father but Jonah simply replies that he
will make a Time Lapse video of his kids
growing up farming his unborn children
for YouTube
Joan is ahead of his time he even
mentioned some insensitive things which
offends the lesbian couple after this he
departs home along with Stevie hoping
that he will get a positive response
from the couple sadly the next day
Stevie receives a call from Allison who
mentions that Jonah is too immature to
have a baby hence they have decided
against the arrangement when Jonah hears
of this he gets frustrated and starts
mentioning that his life is unfair
however Stevie calms him down and tells
him that he should keep trying being the
good friend that she is Stevie decides
to set Jonah up with another of her
colleagues named Claire she is a
middle-aged woman who is not looking to
get married but just wants to have an
affair this time Stevie talks to Claire
herself and describes the date as an
arrangement that night Jonah and Claire
meet each other as instructed by Stevie
and instantly get attracted soon they
get massively drunk and start kissing on
the road the next morning Stevie meets
with Claire at work and asks how the
date went Claire reveals that it was
awesome and that Jonah is a wonderful
guy but she can't go through with the
procedure since she doesn't know him
well this confuses Stevie and she was
pretty sure that Claire would agree to
it she quickly confronts Jonah about
last night and the latter mentions that
he couldn't Harden his manhood because
of the excessive tequila that he
consumed it finally Dawns on Stevie that
this was the reason why Claire broke off
the arrangement she berates Jonah for
ruining the plan and then storms inside
her room desperate Jonah follows her
inside and pleads with her to convince
Claire for a second chance he even
mentions that he will give her house to
Claire if she agrees hearing this Stevie
has taken aback and she tells Jonah that
it is a ridiculous idea however deep
down inside she starts considering it
herself Jonah also mentions that at this
point he is willing to do whatever he
can to convince a lady to have kids with
him this makes Stevie freeze for a while
but she soon snaps out of it and tells
Jonah to go outside as she has to change
that night the house hosts another party
and as you usual Jonah gets drunk he
then gathers some courage and sends a
voice message to Stevie requesting her
to consider his proposal the next
morning he wakes up to a text from
Stevie who calls him to her room there
she reveals that she will accept his
proposal but only if he accepts her
terms and conditions she then hands him
a long list of conditions which Jonah
takes hours to read one of such
conditions states that the whole
Arrangement will be a secret while
another one mentions that there will be
no intimacy between them Jonah inquires
as to why she is willing to go through
with all of this to which Stevie replies
that she loves the house and she wants
to have freedom for the rest of her life
after a while Jonah finally finishes
reading and he signs the contract hence
starting their strange relationship he
also mentions that they only have a week
to make their plan work in the next
scene the duo heads to the department
store and starts collecting the
necessary tools for their plan later
they head to a hotel where Stevie
explains the entire procedure to Jonah
she mentioned that she only has four
days to conceive before her menstrual
cycle kicks in she then hands Jonah a
bucket and a syringe for the procedure
however Jonah becomes over excited and
breaks the syringe compelling them to
head back to the store sadly the store
is closed and they are forced to return
Stevie gets angry that Jonah wasted
their first day but the latter suggests
that they do it naturally Jonah's just
running the world's longest con to get
laid at first Stevie resists telling him
that they have been best friends for a
long time but when Jonah mentions that
he will make it quick she agrees with
this the duo gets in bed and awkwardly
starts the process but soon they get
into it and start performing vigorously
after the encounter the couple becomes
more comfortable and they start having
romantic activities every day Gus starts
doubting them but the two convince him
that nothing is happening between them
meanwhile Jonah and Stevie slowly start
falling in love without either of them
realizing it one day while Stevie is at
work work she heads to the bathroom to
inspect for good news but finds out that
her menstrual cycle is on time this
devastates her as all the effort she and
Jonah put in through the days has gone
in vain she quickly calls Jonah and
tells him to meet up in the parking lot
wasting no time Jonah approaches her
expecting good news however when Stevie
tells him the truth he becomes
devastated one thing leads to another
and the two get into a small argument
causing Stevie to storm out of the place
when Jonah returns home he finds a large
mass of people gathered outside his
house for the scheduled party with all
hopes now gone Jonah decides to enjoy
the party to the fullest before he gets
operated on the next day later that
night Gus informs Jonah that he has
called someone over to meet him when
Jonah heads to the living room he finds
Ava waiting for him turns out that Gus
revealed everything about Jonah's
condition to her hoping that she will
conceive with him Ava quickly takes
Jonah upstairs and apologizes for
everything she said wrong during their
last meeting she also met mentions that
despite them being apart for the last
six months he is still a big part of her
life and that she will do anything for
him with this the two start getting
romantic and start the activity however
before Jonah concealed the deal he
withdraws his manhood causing him to
fire outside the hole our writer is
having fun with this one confused Ava
asks why he did so to which Jonah
replies that it just didn't feel right
as he is in love with someone else
meanwhile Stevie arrives downstairs and
starts searching for Jonah to apologize
to him sadly when she reaches upstairs
she finds Jonah coming out of the room
along with Ava this devastates her and
she quickly leaves the place despite
Jonah trying to explain as she tries to
drive away in her car Jonah clings onto
the back and injures himself compelling
Stevie to stop following this Jonah
confesses his love for Stevie but the
latter replies that she wants to have
babies which she can never have with him
saying this much she drives away while
Jonas stands alone heartbroken in the
next scene Jonah is accompanied by Gus
Katie and her children to the hospital
later when the doctor is questioning him
Stevie arrives there Katie immediately
deduces that her brother is in love with
Stevie and clears the room for them
after this Stevie apologizes for her
statements from the previous night but
Jonah mentions that she didn't say
anything wrong he then mentions that he
is content with being a cool Uncle
rather than a father meanwhile Gus
enters the room and hugs his best friend
telling him that everything will be fine
however as he prepares to leave with
Stevie she gets emotional and kisses
Jonah right in front of Gus the movie
ends as Jonah is taken into the
operation room while Gus cucked all the
way to the moon and back is left in
utter disbelief as to what just happened
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching